ah la vache tchenko est en mission suite
à une alerte à la bombe
c'est la onzième alerte en un mois dans
cette ville à travers le pays la police
a dû fouiller plus de 3000 bâtiment
depuis début 2000 22 pour les autorités
le responsable est tout trouvé la russie
s'est
c'est un élément de la guerre hybride
pour créer le chaos l'incertitude du
lendemain est un état de stress constant
pour que les écoles faste à
l'enseignement à distance et que les
entreprises ferment la dow jones après
ces business
certaines écoles du pays ont en effet dû
fermer à cause des alertes celle ci
continue de fonctionner au ralenti hier
ils ont évacué tout mouvement nous ont
prévenu à la dernière minute pour ne pas
consacrer à qu'ils ont nés les enfants
vers une autre école pas loin avant tout
c'est un stress pour les enfants qu'ils
ont très peur et les parents aussi et
tant que femme
aujourd'hui l'école a décidé de rester
ouvertes soc 2 les groupes catholiques
nous avons créé un groupe de parents et
d'employés de l'école pour fouiller les
jugeront la police est venue aussi
allongeant tout fait très vite et c'est
pourquoi on n'a pas évacué les enfants
et notamment aux niveaux qu'elle est
idiot mais c'est un jeu de roulette
russe les services secrets ukrainiens
affirment justement avoir démantelé un
gang piloté par la russie à jitomir
ce groupe planifié une série d'attaqués
armées dans notre région l'un des
membres est un citoyen russe
nous avons trouvé chez eux des munitions
des armes à feu et des explosifs et
aussi des ordinateurs et des disques
durs qui contiennent des preuves des
crimes qu'ils planifiaient de retour que
d'options
selon les experts en sécurité ukrainiens
des attaques de l'intérieur pour
déstabiliser le pays serait plus
probable qu'une invasion à grande
échelle par la russie